at this lab in London they developed
diagnostic tests for Great Ormond Street
Hospital and Britain's National Health
Service I've come to find out if a new
device made by scientists in Texas could
change the way some tests are done
taking them out of the lab and closer to
patients
I find biomarkers which are blood
markers are ural our cause of disease I
take those markers and I develop them
into tests which we put into chemical
pathology building at Great Ormond
Street Hospital and also any other
hospitals throughout Britain so what
does a normal biomarker test involve how
many steps are there so there are many
steps that are involved the first step
is the clinician meeting the patient's
taking blood from the patient blood then
has to be taken to chemical pathology
building where the blood is separated
into plasma white blood cells red blood
cells those samples will then be put
into a machine by a technician the
samples will be run the data will then
be taken out put onto a computer system
which we then passed to a clinician will
interpret the results what kind of
machines then are you using to read the
samples so the machines we use are
anything from a simple perimeter which
is a desktop machine to anything is
really complex like the mass
spectrometers that we have a great honor
to the hospital
so this is a quadrupole time-of-flight
mass spectrometer this noisy beast is a
very sophisticated weighing machine it's
used to identify and measure proteins it
takes about 24 hours to prepare samples
and get results I think you wouldn't get
much change out of a half a million and
possibly you're talking some of them can
up to a million pounds so and they
probably cost about 50,000 pounds a year
to run as well so the results come out
here on the screen a machine like this
is essential for research and
identifying rare disease markers but for
routine tests scientists in Texas wanted
something cheaper and more portable with
a quick turnaround time so they made the
v-chip each chip costs about 10 u.s.
dollars they're made from two glass
plates which slide together and
preloaded with antibodies and red ink
the protocol is a standard eliezer assay
with a twist you add your patient sample
and the antibodies capture your
biomarker you then add other antibodies
which carry the enzyme catalase by
sliding the plates the catalase is mixed
with hydrogen peroxide and it produces
oxygen the oxygen gas pushes red ink
along a channel the more biomarker in
the sample the more gas produced and the
further up the ink travels so within
minutes you get quantitative results
displayed directly on the chip I mean
the idea is elegant and the principle is
cool but it needs to be simplifies or as
as we say can pass when we do that need
to be born proved what kind of tests
might be suitable for this feature then
so in situations where you need a very
fast turnaround of results for instance
if someone came in fitting or
unconscious certainly I wouldn't want to
diagnose something like cancer or
something like that but if someone comes
in unconscious and you want to know what
drug they've taken an overdose off then
it could be extremely useful I think
you